this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house all right what's happening you
savage it's Monday the 20th of March the
joint is brought to you by Uncle Joey's
favorite liquid IV maybe you forgot
about that New Year's resolution you
made to prioritize your health but I
didn't get back to it Tarzan with liquid
IV the hydration the hydration brand
that fuels your well-being it's easy you
mix one stick of liquid IV with 16
ounces of water and it hydrates you two
times faster than water alone are you
kidding me or what with five essential
vitamins great flavors and three times
the electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks you'll be ready to crush your
health loads goals I'm sorry let me tell
you how them liquid IV has some
tremendous flavors to the strawberry the
tropical punch the cherry and the
concord grape are my favorite you
understand me they also have kombucha
the sour apple it'll knock your socks
off grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or get 20 off when
you go to liquid iv.com use promo code
Joey come on I'm Gonna Get You 20 off
right now anything you order the better
hydration today use promo code Joey at
liquid.com that's promo code Joey at
liquid
iv.com the joint is also brought to you
by
stamps.com listen nobody got time to go
to the Post Office Print all your stamps
you need at La Casa with stamps.com get
rates you can't find anywhere else like
84 percent off ups and USPS they'll even
send you a free scale who does that
nobody so you'll have everything that
you need to get to the post office and
get your party started I love stamps.com
why we've been working with them for
about 12 years now nothing but positive
experiences you can trust stamps.com for
over 25 years they've helped over a
million businesses I don't care if you
have 2 000 employees or three employees
stamps.com is going to change the way
you do business so set your business up
for Success when you get started with
stamps.com today not tomorrow today sign
up with promo code Joey
j-o-e-y for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone on
the top of the page and then the code
Joey it's that easy let's get this party
started the baby it's Monday morning
we got [__] to do and people to see
[Music]
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
okay
what's happening you bad [__]
who cares [__] YouTube is still gonna
take it down it's Monday the 20th a
beautiful [__] day to be alive spring
has come you know what I'm saying Lee
was saying to me you know it's spring
aren't you excited I go yeah I'm excited
now it's hot out now I get to stand
outside with the people I don't like you
know what I'm saying it's the same
[__] thing spring is great I love it
it's gonna rain a lot it's been [__]
cold in Jersey last couple days that's
why I got the heavy excuse me I'm still
burping up my little chocolate milkshake
my little protein shake made with water
and [__] protein powder who the [__]
when did this become popular I got to
put like 20 ice cubes in my blood do
they give the [__] protein shake
substance water with protein I mean
listen milk will [__] clog me up
anyway
I mean I do like two protein shakes a
week I have this other recipe that I do
it
raspberries coconut water and vanilla
protein powder I just can't find the
vanilla protein powder I think that's
how to stock the [__] covet put it
back in uh you know everybody's delayed
I don't know what the [__] happened when
I got here it was always dead of vanilla
protein powder now and it's a certain
vanilla protein powder like protein
powders taste like dick let's get that
[__] out of the way there was one
protein powder that I loved and that's
on its uh the original protein the cacao
Shake protein they had was so [__]
delicious
it was so [__] delicious and then
they had they switched over to the
Mexican chocolate and that was good too
but all I I try you know when you go to
a [__] vitamin place you try I try
like the littlest container of the
protein powder I've tried like three of
them they taste like dick see when I was
a kid you had egg and milk protein that
tasted like nothing so when you made a
shake you just put two scoops of that in
a [__] some Haagen-Dazs vanilla ice
cream in that [__] and some we
germ forget about it you'll be [__]
humming like a bird cocktuckus
people keep asking me why don't I run
for [__] uh politics and I'm like you
know what I'm a felon but then I'm like
wait
your [__] Santos could pull it off
I could definitely pull it off guys
this [__] guy I mean you know just
the I keep laughing at this [__] that he
[__] beats some guy out of dog money
or some [__] like this I've done a lot
of creepy [__] things but I'm gonna
beat somebody out of [__] dog money
that's for God damn sure
but it's a beautiful day we got a great
week coming up we got a [__] arrest
warrant for Putin we got [__] Trump's
going to jail tomorrow there's gonna
arrest warrant for him I mean you know
I'm not even into politics and I don't
give a [__] but I'm kind of jealous
everybody's got an arrest warrant
where's my warrant how come I don't
[__] get arrested last week I almost
got a [__] arrested
this is a great story for you guys
because people are losing their [__]
minds guys
I leave jiu jitsu I'm behind my friend
Ken Chan
we're both like I'm right behind them
maybe
two car legs I'm doing the speed limit
okay
there's a Carvel on the corner in Old
Bridge off of 520s my favorite [__]
carvela to drive through and they've
been there since Jesus left Chicago the
woman who owns it when she's working
there in the daytime that's the best
[__] Carvel anything you'll ever get
in your life she's been working with
them for Years anyway
we're right there I'm counting the
numbers seven
six
five so I know I gotta beat this jersey
yellow
so I see Ken runs the the yellow as soon
as it turns so I got time and I run the
yellow only I'm looking straight ahead
and as Ken runs the yellow a person is
sitting there with that [__] Toyota
whatever the [__] it is
and waiting now this person could have
waited till he gone
but no he stepped on it he or she
God forbid he she he stepped on it
cutting my friend off like my friend was
just [__] beating a light and you
want to pull out in front of him slowly
you dumb [__]
so now I see her blow him go this way
and my friend Ken goes around but now
I'm stuck with her I've been [__] you
know I'm busting through that light and
now I slow it down
she wasn't even doing 40.
what 30. she kept it like that for five
minutes at like 20.
and now the people behind me are beeping
at me and I'm like what the [__] it's
not me you know I can't say anything I'm
just driving the [__] car and I'm
like what the [__] is this lady doing or
this man whatever the [__] it is because
he got dented windows so finally you
know 20 miles of [__] hour I'm doing
22 behind her
definitely a 35 or a [__] 40. after
five minutes I get [__] fed up as
[__] I got [__] to do I gotta take a
[__] I'm hungry I gotta meet somebody at
three I [__] gun that car you know
when it was legal to go around there
they had the one line you know
I go around I'm doing like [__] I
just she she had me pinned for so
[__] long
that when I blew around I just had to
get the [__] out I'm like this lady I'm
gonna kill this dumb [__] so I
pull around and I just take the [__] off
right I take it I get on the [__]
nine
I'm about to hit the nine and do you
know
I look up at the rearview mirror and
here that car comes with smoke coming
out of it it's doing like a hundred you
were doing 20. for [__] 10 minutes
now you want to be [__] speed racing
she pulls up next to me and says she
African-American woman cute as [__]
she pulls up
and she goes excuse me and she got a
phone in the hand I taped you when I
called the police
uh I'm trying to drive my son I'm doing
the speed limit and I I was just looking
at her like I'm not even gonna say
nothing this ain't enough to say and she
goes are you listening to me I'm gonna
call the police and they're going to
arrest you for speeding by me and and
you know I got my son in the car and I'm
trying to be safe she had Georgia plates
and I go stop it right there
stop right there so you do doing 20 but
then for the last half mile you're doing
80 to catch up to me get the [__] out of
my face the light turned green I just
went when I was at the next slide down
she comes around again with the cell
phone again like you know I'm gonna call
the police call the police what do I I
mean I didn't do nothing I didn't first
off guys I got a zero points on my
[__] license and it's been like that
for the last [__] 15 years
okay I've got you know I got zero points
on my license I think the most points
I've ever had of my license was two in
Colorado because I ran the [__] I was
doing 40 and a 35 oh one of those
blinking lights with the [__] school
zone and I was [__] uh another time I
did something oh I was driving with uh a
car uh I was for sale signed car one of
those [__] dealer cars and I had like
1998 clearance you can't drive with ink
on your [__] windshield so they gave
me a point for that that's the most I've
ever [__] had
so I obey the [__] driving rules as I
don't obey [__] but I gotta tell you
something you can't do dick without a
[__] car you could do plenty without
this plenty without that but you lose
your [__] driving poses your driving
privileges you don't know what life is
and trust me what I'm telling you you
lose your driving privileges you don't
know what life really is I never lost my
driving privileges privileges but for a
long time I had to [__] drive around
a bus and guys it sucks to lose your
[__] driving privilege I'm just
letting you know so that was my
adventurous week every week I have
something with the cop I mean I haven't
talked to a cop in here it's not gonna
[__] wood but I always have some lady
driving somebody's not [__] happy a
couple weeks ago I went to get something
at the [__] uh at the health food
store a lady outside somebody hit a car
okay what do you want from me well you
know there was only there's only four
cars in the parking lot it had to be one
of you guys
lady you're parked all the way over
there
and I'm parked all the way over there on
it well I like to call the police and
take a picture of your car I'm taking a
picture of all four cards listen lady
you're not doing nothing
I got [__] to do when people to see if
you want to call the cops take my
license plate tell them I left the scene
of an accident but there was no accident
there was nothing
there was nothing your car is over there
and I'm [__] over here so every week
is [__] something anyway
what I want to talk to you about today
is I got good news I [__] uh the
audio book is done
it wasn't a pain in the ass at all it
was nice and smooth you know I hadn't
looked at that story
since I submitted it in a year and a
half ago I submitted that maybe
15 months ago
so the first couple days of going
through it I was just learning my I was
just learning the [__] uh the ropes I
was just learning my pace and whatnot
I was doing like three hours a day
and I went through the chapters the
night before
just to make it smoother just to know
where I had to take pauses and stuff
like that
you know when you do an audio book you
don't want to be like and I know when
you listen to it you're gonna go Joey
what are you [__] stupid there's
Parts in there where I can tell you're
reading yeah but it has to be more
communication like me just very uh
nonchalant very uh whatever
and it was funny you know all the
chapters uh were still intact what I do
have to say about the book is
there's a couple stories you heard
already
but the beauty of the book is it gives
you the back story
to why that story is special and why I
remembered that story
that'll help you understand
more about what I was going through at
the time
you know the book is in three phases
it's my early life
life after my mother died and then my
comedy life you know so we get them
together at one point it's like kind of
like Aerosmith's book I like it's gonna
mix and it's going to confuse you but
once you read more you'll understand
what the [__] we're talking about
and I got to tell you the chapters that
were most fascinating to me
that I forgot about my life early with
my Early Childhood there was a lot of
[__] that I looked at and even though we
went through it and stuff I was like wow
since we wrote the book I haven't really
thought about that or maybe I hadn't
thought about that
since the thought came up to me that I
had to put that in the book you know
and there was one chapter that really
stuck out with me in the last two weeks
I mean all the chapters are good and
every
self-explanatory there's some funny
stuff in there
but uh it's so funny how when you tell a
story and write a story and read it when
you listen to a story and then read the
same story it's two different things it
really does
like the hooker Story made me [__]
how
you know even though I've lived that
book of story a thousand times reading
it made me [__] how you know
but one of the stories in that book that
really resonated with me and I hope it
resonates with you guys because it was
well it resonated with me to me it was
bigger than what had appeared in the
book that's what I'm trying to [__]
say
little liquid IV a little strawberry I'm
out of the [__] concord grape in the
Cherry but the strawberry is kicking
[__]
but there was uh you know my mother died
that's the big anchor in the story but
before my mother died what made my
mother's debt even more sensationalized
was you know in the eighth grade I
played
in 78 I played a
25 [__] years ago no
that's 22 and then 23 45 [__] years
ago interesting year interesting you
know I played for St Michael's for two
years I had to take a bus back and forth
you know uh we came back and when you're
in the eighth grade it's just great to
take a bus with your friends and after
that you [__] get a slice of pizza I
don't know if we smoke pot then yeah I
think I did but like every quarterly
like I smoked pot you know
wasn't like a daily [__] thing and
we would go to practice like twice a
week and it was a great team some of
these guys are still around I'm gonna
see these guys next Saturday night
uh Whitey and my friend Chucky and just
a couple guys that I haven't seen
basketball friends
and
a couple of us played together down
there Mike Hennessey from Emerson he's
working for the town now in North Bergen
uh the lot the center for the Green Bay
Packers
forget what his name is number 52 was in
the eighth grade with us he was out of
uh Emerson high school he played for
sacred for
Saint Michael's also we were tight group
of kids who who knew we were in the
eighth grade
we just showed up and practiced I
remember we broke into the [__] uh
Catholic Diocese one night we stole all
the the stickers for the booster that he
had to sell for a dollar and we got a
[__] hit beaten from the priest over
there it was just you know
it's a it was a one of those kid
memories that you look back on you know
that was a lot of [__] fun
and there were chilies you know and we
were not sexually active we were nothing
we were just dreaming of kissing a girl
at the [__] time probably you know
dancing slow with them at a [__]
dance or something like that
and you know I had met girls along the
way and we held hands and whatever who
the [__] knows what happened but
I ended up meeting this cheerleader
and I liked her even more because she
wasn't from North Bergen she was from
Union City she was just a nice sweet
Irish girl freckles red hair cuter than
[__] hung out girlfriends were hotter
than [__] she hung out with a Cuban girl
that was great and a little Another
Irish chick and you know be like me and
[__] uh
I forget these kids anymore Hennessy and
we'd [__] after practice we'd always
go around the corner to a pizza place in
Union City and get some pizza where now
it's [__] uh Obama That's the name of
the grammar school or the middle school
it's like Obama it's [__] beautiful
when I went down there to get a a thing
a couple of years ago I was I mean I had
a [__] it was breathtaking
of how much has changed down there you
know
but we I knew that area well like I had
been in Union City all my life that area
down there I I kind of knew the only
time I went down and like that on the
20th Street area was to get THC Crystal
angel dust there was a bar
on like 22nd Street and New York Avenue
across the street from the county morgue
and uh we go down there to get pizza
something there was a movie theater down
there a Cuban movie theater called uh
Cena Tony
that had American movies with Spanish
subtitles and the owner had a wig and
we'd throw penis at his wig and [__]
like that you know I had been down there
but I was I didn't know the area like
Union City where my mother's bar was
so you know in the eighth grade I meet
this girl and we're all friends
afterwards you know I like it the
cheerleaders are coming out with the
basketball players to eat and we go to
the pizza ball and we'd sit together and
we were awkward you know we were
socially awkward with these girls but
you know we talked to them we were kind
of like gentlemen nobody was really
cursing and I started talking to this
one girl and we kind of became tight you
know we would just talk talk and one day
she gave me a number and I would talk to
her at night and you know what we became
kind of an item when I say an item I
mean like we would after a game when we
played games we played them by North
Bergen up by West New York or something
so after the games we'd walk down
Bergenline Avenue holding hands and
torturing Chinese owners and [__]
going into album stores and talking
about the albums we wanted to buy kid
[__] and we go like Burger King with
them and buy them like a chicken
sandwich and we'd hold hands and that's
it it was no big [__] deal we went
home and we dreamed about putting
cologne on and making out with them one
day whatever the [__] you dream of it's
a [__] 13 year old
well I [__] uh
you know we start making out after a few
months we're together like from
maybe November to maybe
February until the season's over we're
together
and then once the season ended I didn't
have a reason to go down there
so it kind of got tough to go down there
so I would go down there maybe like on
Saturdays
and we take a walk on Bergenline maybe
go to a movie you know stupid kitchen I
know you people want to hear like where
you're [__] her where you're lighting
the [__] on fire not even close man not
even close I wasn't even thinking like
that back then I was just happy with
holding the girl's hand and swapping
spit and going to a movie with them I
wasn't even thinking of [__] sex or
nothing but that didn't last for long
so it was uh one of those president
weekends like in February the season
probably ended the first week of
February and it was like present season
it was like uh it's not how it is now
where they have President's Day and you
have both presidents they celebrate uh
Washington and Lincoln so let's say my
birthday was the 19th and that was
February 19th on a Monday that'd be
Washington's birthday but the 12th the
Monday before would be Lincoln's
birthday
so I I don't know I don't know if it was
a holiday I don't know what the [__] it
was I think we got a lot of snow
and with the schools were closed for
like a week
and we kept talking about I don't know
one night we were swapping spit or
something she said something about
second base
or something about sucking their titties
and again I wasn't even there like I was
still a Catholic kid I thought if I
would suck a titties or try to touch a
[__] I was going to hell you know how
you're a [__] geek when you were a
kid
so I don't know we were just talking
about it and
she was like I think I'm ready for the
next step
and I'm like What's the next [__]
step I don't know
and she's like I don't know maybe we
should drive home guys I had no idea so
I went down there with her a couple
times and we kind of dry humped and
swapped spit
I mean we we had no place to go we were
in the [__] eighth grade so I would
have to like dry hump her outside on a
wall behind St Michael's you know
disgusting disgusting so this
conversation went on about us
you know
Dayton exclusively and all this [__] I'm
getting ready you know I was in love
with basketball at that time it was like
when I was doing coke My First Love was
cocaine stand online
stand online MOM stand online dad stand
online wife My First Love is cocaine
my second love is [__] comedy you
know at the time there was no comedy but
my [__] love is uh you know [__]
basketball and I was a Catholic kid I
didn't know anything about I heard about
people getting knocked up and [__] so I
was like I'm not I'm not knocking up a
woman you know I was I was very against
I love to tell you I was different and I
was slinging dick in the sixth grade no
so we talked we talk and we're like okay
we don't have school next week
let's make a date
to come down your house
I don't know how we came to the
conclusion like your parents work or
something
and she's like yeah whatever so I go
listen what I'll do is
uh next week I'll come down one day
and we'll [__] hang out whatever
I didn't know what to expect you know so
on Monday morning
it's about 50 degrees you know the
snow's gone there's still shoveling snow
to melt and I take my little bicycle and
I ride it down to 15th Street to St
Michael's and I meet her outside and
we will go back to a house and we drank
like [__] Kool-Aid we made like grape
Kool-Aid with powdered sugar and ice
cubes and we had like Entenmann's coffee
cake we had a some parents bought it or
something
so we walk up to a house we eat we kind
of giggling we put the TV on we start
swapping spit and I knew I was a little
catholic [__] and whatnot but my dick got
hard and I was taking it to the next
level and I got on top of her and we
were dry humping whatever we were just
two [__] kids we didn't know what the
[__] was going on and
she was like what do you want to do you
know when you're a kid you're like what
do you want to do I don't know what do
you want to do I don't know what do you
want to do I don't know you want to say
it you show it to me first no you show
me yours no you should it was one of
those things
and finally I just wanted to be safe and
you know before I was sorry and I go hey
what time do your parents get home
and she goes
well my sister gets home at like five
my dad gets home at like 5 30. and my
mother's dead
and I was like
come again
it's like
you know my father comes home at 5 30.
my sister gets home by five and my
mother's dead and I'm like
dog I think we were holding hands
and I like threw her hands down I'm like
what do you mean your mother's dead
she's like yeah my mother died when I
was a little girl dog
my whole [__] system my whole belief
system just hit the [__] toilet
it was like what
your mother's dead
you know sometimes you do things and
somebody opens your mind up with
something like Mike when you play the
guitar you could throw gasoline on the
top thing and play you know whatever the
[__] you want to do you know people open
up your mind sometimes you're not ready
for something and people up your mind
sometimes when I go to jujitsu they
teach me a move I can't [__] do but
from doing that move I learned something
else I go oh look at this opening here I
never saw that before it's it's called
expanding your mind you know what I'm
saying like it's just it's Evolution
guys when I went down there
I didn't know what to expect you know I
didn't know if I was going to have sex
it's not like I had a condom in my
pocket and I had [__] Kelowna and I
was all [__] hot and sticky
I had uh gone down there just to swap
Spit with him maybe hang out with her I
was an only child I was starting to
explore women girls whatever the [__] I
was doing
when she told me her mother died
my whole [__] everything just
died I was like what the [__] are you
talking about and she started explaining
to me her mother died but the more she
explained it the more I was she was
starting to scare me like it was like an
exorcist type [__] situation for me
like I couldn't even believe I was in
the house at that time Not only was I a
real Catholic Little Nerd but I was also
a Santeria guy and I'm like if I'm in
this house with this [__] energy that
her [__] mother died
well somebody in my life is gonna
[__] die I'm like I'm not gonna hang
out with this girl no more I remember I
made up some story how I had a [__]
leave and I [__] got on my bicycle
and I got the [__] out of there I didn't
call her for like three days guys when I
tell you that you like when a girl turns
you down you get like a little hot
you know or somebody says something to
you get a little hot for like two days
but then you're like what am I gonna do
even though I wanted to mess around with
her and even though I liked her as much
as I did
I [__] knew
I was gonna ever see this girl again
like it was just too much for my body
and my mind to [__] comprehend yes I
had a father who died do you think it's
from that what do you mean like no
knowing how she feels I never Mike I
never at that time as
as stupid as this [__] sounds I never
even know my father was gone
I never comprehended your mom not being
around
I could not comprehend that I had
watched something or something years
earlier where they said
anybody could be your father but you
only have one mother
I think it's a [__] horrible
statement because not everybody could be
your father
and I think that statement ran you know
just went in my head like you know your
mother I got guys I did not understand
the [__] statement
when she said she didn't have a mother
and her mother had died
I'm not joking I'm not trying to be
funny I'm not trying to be cute it
destroyed me because I didn't think that
was possible
I never thought that no matter what bad
a situation I never saw it coming you
know I think I'm Godfather too they
shoot the mother
but that was a movie
like that's a [__] movie and you're
left as a young child I could never even
picture like a mother dying like I
didn't think that was [__] possible
I just could not talk to it took me
about a week
a couple days to call her up and ask her
how she was doing and then she kept
saying to me what am I going to see you
what am I going to see and I kept lying
to her I'm really busy with basketball
uh I gotta go out to Kearney for the
aau's I just kept lying to and no matter
like how much I thought about like I got
a [__] uh
I gotta [__] uh go down there and
just break it up with her like a man
guys I could not get I did not want to
be around how the [__] your mother be
dead all I kept thinking about was what
can you have done in your previous life
for your [__] mother to die that's
all I kept thinking about
more after the little break here now for
a word from our sponsors
what up this episode is brought to you
by Better Health listen learning who you
are is a lifelong journey I'm 60 and I
still don't know who the hell I am but
better helps online therapy can deepen
your self-awareness until you no longer
making decisions you regret I was having
I was struggling when I moved here I was
struggling with couple things and Dana
better helped help me out a ton so do me
a favor if you're struggling take a
quick survey to get connected with a
license better help therapist you won't
be sorry it's convenient flexible
schedule if you don't like your
therapist you could switch therapists
make the change at no additional cost
let me tell you something once you go on
Better Health
you'll be you'll have a therapist within
48 Hours try finding a therapist on your
own it'll take you two years so do me a
favor discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com
Diaz to get 10 percent off your first
month that's right visit betterhelp.com
Diaz today and get 10 off your first
month and be Tip Top Magoo by the summer
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Diaz now it's time to
go back to the show we're back [__]
don't forget go to betterhelp.com so you
don't get stuck like I did for years
back to the story [__]
so that's all I kept figuring out what
can you have done
what did you do in your previous life
did you kill a bird did you run over an
old lady what did you do in your
previous life
that you don't have a [__] mother it
took me about
a month to get the carriage up and I had
to call her up like a man and go
Colleen
you know I really enjoyed dating you
when I said that she goes what are you
talking about
and she wasn't a pain in the ass she
wasn't anything she was a sweet
loving little Irish girl those are the
only girls that ever dated me she had
freckles she had red hair she was
[__] beautiful
but man I could not come to terms of her
not having a mother and I tried
everything I could I mean I was 13.
[__] hormones were raging and that's
what she kept talking to me about like
are we ever going to have sex what are
we going to do when I'm like uh not
[__] never
and we graduated the eighth grade and I
never saw her again I made it a point
not to ever see her again like they
would have little parties and invite my
friends and they'd say hey you got
invited I'm not going down there that
[__] girl don't have a mother
I'm like [__] you I'm not going around
that [__] girl
[Music]
but in a way it made me appreciate
my mother a lot more like I went home
that day and like I didn't say nothing
to my mom
but I was like how the [__] can your
mother die I I could not get over it and
when I called her I even felt worse
because she started crying
and she was like I don't know why you're
doing this and I could never tell her
because you don't have a [__] mother
I could never ever [__] tell her that
and then that was
you know may of 78 maybe April 78
we both graduated in June I didn't see
her again I think she checked in with me
when I got back from Five Star Camp you
know like how did it go I'm cheering for
you for the freshman team because that's
what I told I gotta get ready for the
freshman team I'm [__] starting next
year I got no time to be [__] holding
the hands talking about your dead mother
I did not
telling you guys it [__] it [__]
killed me
so you figured out with 78 you know I
had forgotten about her
never seen her again I went to high
school never [__] saw her again
I bumped into a friend years later the
Cuban girl but we'll get to that story
some other time
uh
I never saw her again
I always felt guilty if you know
anything about me guys I felt guilty
when I called it to break it off for
that day she was very upset [__] that I
can't handle if it was me now I wouldn't
have never broke up but I would have
just understood but I didn't I didn't
[__] understand and you can't be mad
at me for that it was my biggest [__]
fear at the time
because I think I didn't have a father
you're right I didn't have a father so
for me I would be left with nobody like
it was just
[__] I couldn't even think about it I
could not even think about it
and you know for a year and a half I
just lived my life
never thinking about Colleen I did that
purposely I didn't want to think of
somebody who didn't have a [__]
mother
and then November 79 I come home late
one night I'm having a good time I'm on
acid I wake up in the middle of night
and I find my [__] mother and I will
never ever ever forget this moment when
I found my mother on the floor I looked
at the arm the whole [__] she was
dead I made the [__] call I waited
for the ambulance outside they got there
they told me
they told me she was dead you know uh do
you have anybody to call I was like yeah
I'll never forget that as she was
pulling away
like as the ambulance is pulling away
Colleen's thought came to my [__]
head like that you know I was so busy
with my mother and this and that and the
cops and you know Finding paperwork and
her license and whatever the [__] I was
looking for
I remember sitting on those steps and I
thought of Colleen and I just dropped
I just [__] dropped
and I was like holy [__]
this has come full [__] Circle you
know
I I didn't know I should have called her
then I was too busy with my own [__]
grief
but I always thought about it I thought
about her a lot for years how Maybe
even maybe thinking about that death
brought that to my house but all that is
[__] we all know that when your
bingo number comes up [__] your
bingo number comes up you could drink
all the turmeric you want then [__]
olive oil and [__] all the vegan [__]
you want you know when God decides when
your bingo number comes up
all that pomegranate juice they don't
give a [__] you know what I'm saying all
those uh laps you ran nothing matters
after that you know so
I felt guilty about Colleen for years
that I did that to her I mean that I
think in my world that's the worst
[__] crime I've ever done my [__]
life
I stopped being a girl's friend because
she didn't have a mother how disgusting
is that and now there I was two years
later with no [__] mother
and uh for years I thought about Colleen
you know
so about I don't know maybe five years
ago one night I was high on whatever the
[__] I was on and I looked her up on
Facebook and there she was
she's still beautiful
if I'm 60 she's got to be like 58
uh real pretty face she's married one of
her kids is not well one of her sons is
not well
until this day
I don't find the strength to apologize
to
I've apologized to everybody I got
kidnapped my ex-wife teachers you know
I've I've learned to apologize to
everyone
for some reason I cannot [__] write
an apology to this girl
maybe call her up
you know uh so that's my goal for the
next couple weeks to figure out
that'll be full circle for me I gotta
figure out how to Apollo and she doesn't
even [__] know
I'm not going to say it to her I'm just
going to tell her that I'm sorry you
know what happened between us I know
we're fond about each other
but my head was somewhere else you know
I'm not sure if she reached out to me
and my mother died I'm not sure
I really really got to think about it
because now I'm telling the story I
remember her Cuban girlfriend coming
through awake
but I don't know if she was one of them
but man
if you want to know what haunts me today
it's not a lot of [__] that you think
that would haunt me it's that story that
story is always [__] me up
because man I remember when it came back
into my head that night after that
ambulance took off and I was like [__]
now I know what this really [__]
feels like I I
I gotta figure something out and guys
it's been 45 years
and I still can't figure out what to say
to her
Mike I have no idea and I got The Gift
of Gab I could talk to anybody you know
I could talk to an Indian I could talk
to a Spanish guy I still won't even know
how
to [__] end to this conversation with
scariest [__] thing in the world man
but it's crazy that things that we hide
or that we did and it's crazier things
that you hide it's crazy things I've
apologized to for people
this is just a little bit [__] too
hard for me man I've apologized to my
uncle we held guns on each other I
apologize Jesus Christ I've apologized
for every creepy thing I've [__] done
man
but this I just can't get over
apologizing to this girl
I wouldn't even know where to start but
I do promise you guys at home
because we all work together on
coming full circle that I will have to
do this maybe I'll do it before there's
two things I got to do before this book
gets released
it's apologized to her
and tell my daughter about
her older [__] sister and why we
don't talk and that's going to be really
[__] hard those two things man those
are the two hardest things I've ever had
to do forget about talking to judges
forget about coming clean with my
ex-father-in-law after I kidnapped the
dude
like I said I have no problems with
apology but these two
well the one I don't have to apologize
to but this girl is this is gonna
[__] destroy me
before I told the story on here today I
went on the Facebook page just to make
sure she was still there and she's still
there waiting for me to apologize to her
it doesn't even have to start as an
apology to see how she is and where
she's been and what see if she did that
reach out to you that'd be something to
start the conversation
yeah she lives somewhere in New Jersey
it's not close to him it's one of those
farm towns I don't [__] know where it
is Jersey is a [__] huge man Jersey
is huge like I didn't know how big
Jersey was until I moved back here and
when people send me [__] like hey are
you coming to this next Saturday I'll go
on waves it's like an hour 42 what it's
like that night I was gonna go see Rudy
in uh Vineland it was like an hour 20 or
some [__] like that I'm like I'm not
[__] driving no hour 20. I thought
Vineland was down the [__] block man
but yeah it's amazing what we could
apologize for and what we can't
apologize for and I know a lot of you
guys listen to this podcast you
[__] got some apologies to make
to people so we all do we all do man and
we try to brush it off and stuff
listen if you know anything about me I
wouldn't give a Frenchman's [__] about
this girl or the apology
I just feel for my own you know what I'm
saying sometimes you have to do things
for you I just feel
for my own piece of [__] mind
that I gotta call her not calling just
message her on Facebook
but I don't know what the apology is for
how do I apologize because she's got a
dead mother do I apologize because I
broke up with her because she had a 10
months
[Music]
[__] 18 year old guy could have felt
mature about that situation I mean the
way you reacted was a little well listen
man let's get something [__] straight
and every man hates to [__] say this
I have come to terms with this and I say
it all the time and I could see one when
I see one
you're either a mama's boy or you're
[__] not
I could cut it any way I can I could put
tattoos on my head and be [__] super
this and super that you're a mama's boy
okay and I think that was
that's the [__] answer right there I
was a [__] mama's boy I could not
even imagine
not having a mom and here I am
45 years later with no Mom and I got to
be honest I'm still waiting for my mom
to make a comeback like John Lennon yeah
I'm still waiting for the both of them
to come in together singing songs I saw
a woman the other day I looked just like
Yoko Ono in a car way that a light and I
was making a right turn she looked so
much like Yoko action I had to stop and
I looked at her like for two seconds and
went Yoko and he just took off and she
was like why does everybody keep calling
me that well because you [__] look
like Yoko
oh my God
she's 90 years old most people that sung
that bad would die when they're 61.
we've had so many great musicians that
died [__] Biggie Tupac but meanwhile
Yoko is still [__] alive
pouring out bad music with that son
that's never done a [__] thing
Sean's never done a thing the other
one's pretty good yeah no he's all gone
too he sang One song and he was done
come on he was he he came out after John
died what's the other one the other one
I forget his name he looks just like his
father and these things just like him he
was on toilet Primus recently really
I'm pretty sure yeah he kept doing
something but the young ones Sean Sean's
not doing nothing he did one thing
Sean's not doing Sean's playing [__]
chopsticks for Yoko that's that's not
healthy for [__] anybody man
it's not healthy for none of these
[__]
can't believe it's [__] spring
I didn't even know [__] till yesterday I
looked at the calendar I'm like
it's [__] spring is it today or
Tuesday the 21st tomorrow is [__]
spring
yesterday was brutal it's 37 degrees on
Sunday
today's kind of [__] nice and by the
end of the week it's supposed to be
[__] 70 degrees here in Jersey it's
crazy that it did not snow
this is two [__] years that I
expected I mean that ate my words every
year I'm like yeah there's always snow
on the 19 [__] you better check your
itinerary you couldn't you couldn't
build an igloo for an ant in this
[__] there's no snow at all it's
really [__] weird how this all
changed like in 40 years this changed
this much 40 years ago I was walking
around this [__] neighborhood and
you'd be [__] freezing at the end of
March it was freezing still it wasn't
February of [__] January
but it was [__] freezing so
This Global whatever the [__] they're
talking about I'm gonna stay away from
it because I don't know nothing and I
know they've politicized it like the pot
like the pandemic whatever the [__]
people talk about they've they've
politicized it I don't even know what
that means I'm just using Bill Maher
words right now just to just to be a
little [__] uh yeah
and that's it guys it's a beautiful
[__] Monday it's a beautiful [__]
week to be you [__] and pretty
much we got another month till the books
gets released so I'm excited about that
I'm excited that we got done with the
audio book
I'm excited that we cut the podcast down
to once a week and more alert I'm
excited I'm not ready to do stand up yet
I'm just excited to be [__] excited
but I want to talk to you about
something guys real quick
I'm not every Sunday I get a
notification on my computer
on the little iPad and it tells you this
week you were down
18 you used your computer you know
I noticed that the last three months
I've been really down like it's like
Joey what the [__] where you been you
used to post every day now you post once
a week or you post twice a week
but it's funny I between posting and
when I wake up in the morning sometimes
you know listen YouTube is the Earl is
the
easiest thing for me to listen to music
sometimes I'll think of an album like
this last week I've been Mike will tell
you I'm hooked on dirt again the album
Dirt by Alice in Chains is [__]
Sensational and you forget how good
these arms are and sometimes you put
them on two weeks ago it was Diary of a
Madman you know a week before that it
was Santana I'm one of those [__]
guys I like music
but every time I go to YouTube
if there's
nine videos
on this page here
two of them are about health
one of us about side control
one of them is music and the other ones
are just [__] hate
like
oh my God and and there's no particular
they just hate on everybody and I'm
gonna explain hate to you because I
didn't understand hate
until I started comedy and there was a
guy Andrew Dice Clay that made me laugh
now and he made he made me laugh then
and he still makes me laugh now
and I watched him go from
being a great comic
to an overhead overnight sensation I
mean let's [__] face it he was the
first Arena comic you know this guy was
doing numbers you could never dream
about I remember I was there I was part
of his fan club you know I liked what he
did I wasn't one of these Knuckleheads
you know say a poetry thing no but I
enjoyed him
I was there when
you know he went on the MTV thing and he
went said whatever he did and he got
banned from MTV you know I still
remember these things
and I saw him from an HBO special he did
live in Philadelphia
it's just become this [__] rock and
roller and I remember his you know there
was no internet back then but I remember
every day his uh
his name was in the paper every [__]
day
and I know that you guys think that
you're hating that you're you know doing
something spectacular and I get it
there's not a lot I don't like everybody
either that's what makes this world so
special that we all can't like everybody
but I'm not gonna sit there every day
and make a video about some comic I do
not like
you know for you people who love making
these videos
you're making Brendan's job a
millionaire
do you understand this
listen I like Brendan I respect Brendan
Brendan's a [__] sweetheart of a guy
listen you guys went down there
expecting to see George Carlin and you
saw something else so all of a sudden
they saw his special and you don't like
it and all sudden people started
terrorizing and I know he says
knucklehead stuff from time to time but
I know where Brendan's heart is
and I gotta be honest with you if you
don't like Brandon
that's fine
listen I don't like uh you know Carmel
Rocky Road chocolate and guess what do
you think that [__] Carvel give us a
[__] do you think that [__] Baskin
Robin gives a [__] they don't come in
here and get something that you do like
and that's fine
you know I've I've expressed my [__]
about
Roger Waters and whatever
listen he's a [__] multi-millionaire
I'm not helping that [__] dude I know
everybody knows he's a [__]
but you know when you guys pick on a
comic or an actor or
a band and you go after them like that
all you're doing with all your hate
is putting tons of money in this [__]
pocket
you guys say Brendan sucks guess what
it's like the chick when she died you
know I don't want to go to rehab I said
no no no no
I knew if I go there she's going to be
on heroin I know she might pass out or I
know she might not show up why are
people paying 200 over [__] price tag
to go to those concerts because it might
be the best show it might be the best
show you ever saw but the main thing is
people love a train wreck
and that's what they're doing it for
because people are watching train wrecks
and they're getting paid to make the
train wreck there you go
so
listen I love Hefty skies are they
George Carlin are they Dave Chappelle by
your standards are they Jerry Seinfeld
no neither am I guess what I don't give
a [__]
I didn't opt out to be Jerry Seinfeld or
Louis CK I appreciate them
but I don't give a [__] but when you
guys keep
making videos like I just see random
stupid [__] like it's like you had the
time
to produce this
think of the think of you took that time
and did something positive with your
[__] time you'd be making the same
money he's making by [__] and it goes
into your pocket but you're going to
produce a video you're going to get a
couple of YouTube streams some envelopes
and that's fine
but Brendan's still getting richer and
I'm not saying this is about Brendan I'm
not saying this about Brendan at all I'm
using him as an example because if like
I said if I see 10 videos four of them
about [__] Brendan so it's like guys
knock it off you don't like somebody you
don't like me you don't like a certain
comic move on
move on comedy Central's got a thousand
comics on there Netflix has a thousand
comments and guess what YouTube even has
more comics
so you don't have to bank on these guys
like I said for me they're my friends I
know them I love them I wish them all
well and she'll like that
I don't like that they're getting
[__] uh you know tortured every day
but at the same time
your hate
is creating his [__] bank account and
meanwhile you're struggling to buy the
[__] car payment
so you talk to me about this [__] and
with that I love you [__] with
all my heart thank you for supporting
the [__] joint thank you for your
support of me my patreon and I'll see
you [__] uh next month next
Monday if there's no mouth surgery I'll
keep you [__] posted now for a
word for my [__] sponsors Jack
all right I want to thank you guys for
supporting the joint and for supporting
me and patreon everything we're trying
to do here don't forget to get the book
on Amazon you got to pay for shipping
there's another one thriftbooks.com
where you get free shipping it's 25.99
go there this episode was brought to you
by better help like I said learning who
you are is a lifelong journey better
help is online therapy that can deepen
your self-awareness until you're no
longer making decisions you regret that
sounds tremendous you're like Joey
what's better help their therapy it's
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule so do yourself a favor discover
your potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
Diaz the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com nobody has time to go to a
post office so print all the stamps you
need at home with straps.com
get rates of you can't find anywhere
else like 84 off ups and USPS they'll
even send you a free scale so you'll
have everything that you need like I
said earlier I've been with stamps.com
so long you don't see me going anywhere
else and you don't see me going to the
post office you could truststamps.com
for over 25 years they've helped over a
million businesses so do me a favor get
your business up set your business up
for Success when you get started with
stamps.com sign up with promo code Joey
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts go to stamps.com right now
click on the microphone and enter code
Joey and you won't be going no mailboxes
no more and the joint is brought to you
by come on liquid IV maybe you forgot
about that little New Year's resolution
to get yourself healthy so don't worry
about nothing liquid IV got you back
it's time to get back to liquid IV the
hydration brand that fuels your
well-being it's very easy you mix one
stick of liquid IV with 16 ounces of
water it's going to hydrate you two
times faster than water alone I love it
the concord grape the best Cherry
tremendous tropical tremendous
it's just tremendous five essential
vitamins great flavors and three times
the electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks you'll be ready to crush your
health goals grab liquid IV in Bulk
Nation nationwide at Costco or you can
get listen to this look at your 20 off
when you go to liquid iv.com and use
promo code Joey not 10 I'm doubling the
anti 20
that 20 off anything when you shop
better hydration today use promo code
Joey at liquid IV I want to thank liquid
IV I want to thank stamps.com and I want
to thank better help for making this
better Americans stay black have a great
week and I'll see you Savages next
Monday morning
Tip Top magulu love you
thank you
[Music]